fight against terrorism migration and  data protection will top two discussions  during the next justice and Home Affairs  Council EU home affairs ministers will  start with counterterrorism measures the  focus will be the reinforcement of  border controls combating firearms  trafficking and preventing the promotion  of terrorism on the Internet the Khalsa  will also discuss how to tackle the  recent migratory pressures that the EU  is facing in the Mediterranean and the  Western Balkans on the second day of the  council EU justice ministers will  discuss the data protection regulation  the aim is to establish a one-stop-shop  mechanism to arrive to a single and  consistent supervisory decision on  transnational cases cutting red tape  ministers are also expected to agree on  the principles for the processing of  personal data